Mark Zuckerberg doing something untoward
in regard to like intellectual property
that doesn't sound right guys Mark
Zuckerberg wouldn't do that it's not
like he has a history of that with the
very creation of Facebook to be fair his
his history of trying to create rival
alternative social media platforms has
not fared too well for him that's true
they tried to do a signal type thing
didn't work out they tried to do a
Snapchat type thing didn't work out I am
pretty sure threads will not work out
look man it might but it is a really bad
platform there are people on the left
who are tribally just saying woo it's so
much better and I'm just like dude you
log into the app let me let me I'm gonna
log in right now I'm gonna I'm gonna
pull it up and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna like so first of all it's
recommending AOC to me like crazy I do
not follow AOC on this and uh let's
let's see what what it wants me to so
there are people I follow
and uh I do see their posts